un panneau d'urgence en français en
anglais pour alerter d'une énième
fermeture en cas d'urgence les habitants
et touristes présents à lavelanet
devront se rendre à une trentaine de
kilomètres au centre hospitalier de
saint jean de verges ou encore choisir
la commune de foix pour tenter de se
faire soigner
non mais écoutez c'est un service de
moins à lavelanet surtout lorsqu'on a
des enfants
ça peut être embêtant même pour les
personnes âgées c'est un service de
moins c'est très embêtant premiers êtres
aimés sisal et l'usiné conduit de fait
les quelques trente ou quarante
kilomètres pour aller à l'hôpital
c'est pas bien il nous fait il m'a fallu
me rendre juste pour un diagnostic la
boutique alors il va alors il a fallu
commander le taxi et c'est juste pour
aller à foix quoi elle m'a pris cinq
minutes pour me dire arrêtez l'insuline
que tout va bien pour le moment
voilà c'est idiot on aurait un truc ici
un rôle en quoi le kobe 19 le variant
delta préoccupe tous les indicateurs
sont en hausse dans l'ariège taux
d'incidence taux de positivité personnes
hospitalisées pour pourvoir en médecins
les hôpitaux du département les urgences
de lavelanet ont été sacrifiés au profit
d'un s'est agi d'une commune voisine
cette décision fait suite à
l'aggravation rapide de la situation
sanitaire dans le département de
l'ariège et permet un renforcement
personnel soignant visant à adapter le
capacitaire qu'ovide du centre
hospitalier intercommunal des vallées de
l'ariège durant cette période estivale
elle les syndicats de leur côté pointent
du doigt des manques de moyens
récurrents depuis des mois financiers et
humains une désertification médicale
croissante qui a obligé à faire des
choix
au sein du département c'est reflet du
manque d'effectifs
en réalité vous avez des médecins
urgentistes sur fois qu'ils ont qui sont
en arrêt maladie
il ya des départs qui sont annoncés pour
le mois de septembre est donc la
direction a besoin de simplement de
récupérer du personnel pour pouvoir
faire tourner son service ensuite met à
mal les autres services de
l'établissement puisque vous avez quand
même un service de médecine un service
de soin d'eux
suite de réadaptation qui se retrouvent
sans urgence sur place donc s'il ya un
cas grave on est obligé d'appeler le 15
ce qui n'est pas normal de l'ancien
hôpital pour le maire de lavelanet le
parti pris est inacceptable et les
responsabilités de cette fermeture sont
à chercher du côté de l' agence
régionale de santé d'occitanie je crois
que la rs doit absolument trouver les
moyens pour que à ce niveau là et à bien
d'autres niveaux d'ailleurs mais nous
puissions assurer la sécurité de nos
compatriotes
où que nous soyons et sur tous les
territoires nous sommes un territoire
rural et de montagne
je crois que dans ces conditions la
responsabilité doit être partagée
les urgences c'est plus de six mille
interventions chaque année donc je pense
que c'est un territoire qui a besoin de
ce genre de service
les urgences de lavelanet sont censé
rouvrir le 15 août mais sans garantie la
direction de l'hôpital a déjà prévenu la
réouverture dépendra de l'amélioration
de la situation sanitaire